While I’m a big fan of summer, I’m not
such a fan of the sun.
I get burned in like 2 seconds, but what about
wild animals?
Do they get as sunburned as I do?
Hey sunshine, Julia here for DNews
Animals live in some pretty extreme places,
like the sahara where the sun scorches the
desert.
But it’s not like they go inside and turn
on the AC and call it good.
How do these animals beat the heat?
It’s in the hairs’ shape.
if you were to cut it in half, a cross section
would show it looks like a triangle.
This shape is really good at reflecting energy
in the visible and near-infrared end of the
electromagnetic spectrum.
But because of their unique shape the hair
also is really good at letting the ants cool
off.
They’re “highly emissive in the mid-infrared
portion of the electromagnetic spectrum”.
This way the ants can release some of their
excess body heat.
These hairs appear silvery in bright sunlight
hence their name, the researchers described
the ants appearance as looking “ like droplets
of mercury on the desert surface”
Speaking of weird droplets.
Apparently back in the day circuses used to
advertise hippos that sweat blood!
Turns out, it’s not blood.
It’s sunscreen according to a study published
in the journal Nature.
That’s right, HIPPOS MAKE THEIR OWN SUNSCREEN
TOO.
Which is also helpful when you live in sub
saharan Africa.
When hippos get overheated they excrete two
sticky substances.
One red, one orange.
Both act as really good sunscreens by absorbing
UV light.
But the red pigment also acts as an antibiotic!
So hippos rarely get wounds.
Another study published in the journal Philosophical
Transactions of the Royal Society A found
that the sweat also acts as a sunscreen because
it’s reflective.
The sweat contains microscopic liquid crystalline
structures that scatters light.
The structures look like concentric rings
that occur at intervals similar to the wavelengths
of visible light.
But hippos aren’t alone in their ability
to make their own sunscreen.
Recent research published in the journal eLife
found other animals like Zebrafish can make
their own sunscreen too.
Zebrafish produce a chemical called gadusol
that protects against UV radiation.
Previously this chemical was found in stuff
like fungi or bacteria, and researchers thought
that the fish got the chemical by eating those
things.
Turns out they can make it themselves.
The researchers were investigating compounds
similar to gadusol in fungi and bacteria.
And they found that fish also possess the
genes that code for an enzyme, EVVS, which
reacts with other compounds to produce gadusol.
They also found that some birds and reptiles,
like chickens and alligators have the gene
too.
Since it’s commonly found in algae, the
researchers think it’s an ancient trait.
That trait was passed on to vertebrates and
remained useful for millions of years.
So maybe these species have been making sunscreen
for millions of years or the researchers suggest
that gadusol could be beneficial for other
processes like as an antioxidant, or in stress
response, or embryonic development.
As for us, we do have some natural protection
from the sun and heat.
We’ve got melanin in our skin, which absorbs
both UVA and UVB types of light and might
have other protective properties.
So the more freckles I get, the more protected
I am from sun damage.
But freckles don’t always cut it, so thank
goodness for sun screen.
And for your own protection, do you know what
SPF means?
Basically SPF 30 means you can stay outside
30X longer without burning than if you didn’t
have sunscreen on.
SPF 30 usually protects against 97% of UVB
rays but not against UVA rays, for that you’d
need “broad spectrum sunscreen”.
But the only way to be 100% protected is to
stay inside and be on your laptop all day.
but if you have to go outside, be sure to
lather up.
You’re no hippo.
Whales on the other hand, not so lucky.
Whales get sunburned too!
To learn more check out this great video right
here.
So are you a sun bather or do you prefer to
sit alone in a dark room watching youtube
all summer?